why does your vote matter your vote
matters because in the most specific
case there might be a race where you
live for the house of the Senate or even
the presidency where your vote really
could determine who the winner of that
race is we saw in the 2000 presidential
election race that basically in the
entire presidency was determined by a
difference of 537 votes in Florida so
that's a special case but then also
there are reasons to vote that have
nothing to do with the the people who
are running for the national offices
there are lots of local offices where
laws are are put on the books that
really can affect your day to day life
there's also referendums in various in
various states and localities there are
about a hundred and fifty odd referenda
on everything from whether marijuana
should be legalized to whether and how
poor people get medical coverage those
are also on the ballot in a lot of
places but there's and also when a vote
takes place for somebody who is being
elected it's not just for the policies
of the day it's also for the policies
that may yet come and if you have a view
on the way things should be handled you
should exercise your voice because it
not only even if you are in a place
where your vote is not going to matter
in terms of directly electing the person
you want voting sends a message to those
lawmakers and it sends one of two kinds
of messages one it says this number of
people represents this viewpoint and
lawmakers should listen to that kind of
message from the voters a lot of times
even if they don't listen to it well
their opponents will be able to raise it
and say look this many people believe in
this and you should it is a fact that is
then used in public debate and that fact
can sometimes be used to persuade people
also there's the case that lawmakers get
nervous and they want to get reelected
and if they see a lot of people turning
out on the other side even if it doesn't
keep them from being elected well the
next time it might keep them from being
elected so they have to listen finally
it's the spiritual kind of American
Civic religion which is America started
on the idea that we could govern
ourselves without resorting to fights
and we've been remarkably successful
although American history is blotted
it is broken in places but but Americans
have always transferred power peacefully
to each other with the one great
exception of the Civil War but the
electoral system still survived even
through that most bloody battle and so
as Americans by voting we are putting
ourselves back in touch with this great
original experiment that at its time was
unique in American history and there are
still people all across the world who
fight and die for the simple ability to
cast a vote so that their voice can be
heard and so not only do we have to keep
faith with our own history but also with
the world in which it is a human right
in some places to vote and so we
shouldn't take that kind of thing for
granted if we want a world in which
human beings are allowed to voice their
vote and have that vote means something
in the way the laws are made that
determine how their lives are lived